the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so again welcome to 1801 we're getting
started today with what we're calling
unit 1 highly imaginative topic highly
imaginative title and it's
differentiation so let me first tell you
briefly what's in store in the next
couple of weeks the main topic today is
what is a derivative and we're going to
look at this from several different
points of view and the first one is a
geometric interpretation and that's what
we'll spend most of today on and then
we'll also talk about a physical
interpretation of what a derivative is
and then
there's going to be something else which
I guess is maybe the reason why calculus
is so fundamental and why we always
start with it at in most science and
engineering schools which is the
importance of derivatives of this to all
measurements so that means pretty much
every place that means in science and
engineering in economics in political
science etc polling lots of commercial
applications just just about everything
now so that's what we'll be getting
started with and then there's another
thing that we're going to do in this
unit which is we're going to explain how
to differentiate anything so how to
differentiate any function you know and
that's kind of a tall order but let me
just give you an example if you want to
take the derivative this we'll see today
is the notation for the derivative of
something of some messy function like e
to the X arc tan of X we'll work this
out
by the end of this unit all right
so anything you can think of anything
you can write down we can differentiate
it all right so that's what we're going
to do and today as I said we're going to
spend most of our time on this geometric
interpretation so let's let's begin with
that
so here we go with the geometric
interpretation of derivatives and what
we're going to do is just ask the
geometric problem of finding the tangent
line to some graph of some function at
some point which is say X 0 Y Z so
that's the problem that we're addressing
here I guess I should probably turn this
off all right so here's our problem and
now let me show you the solution so well
let's graph the function so let's say
here's its graph and here's some point
all right maybe I should draw it just a
bit lower so that I don't all right so
here's a point P maybe it's above the
point x0 x0 by the way this was supposed
to be an x0 that was the some fixed
place on the x-axis and now in order to
perform this this mighty fee I will use
another color of chalk how about red
okay so so here it is
there's the tangent line well not quite
straight close enough right I did it
alright that's the end that's the
geometric problem I achieved what I
wanted to do and it's kind of an
interesting question which unfortunately
I can't solve for you in this class
just how did I do that that is how
physically did I manage to know what to
do to draw this tangent line but that's
what geometric problems are like we
visualize it we can figure it out
somewhere in our brains it happens and
the task that we have now is to figure
out how to do it analytically to do it
in a way that a machine could do just as
well as I did in drawing this tangent
line so so what do we learn in high
school about what a tangent line is well
a tangent line has an equation and any
line through point has the equation y
minus y 0 is equal to and the slope
times X minus X so so here's the the
equation for that line and now there are
two pieces of information that we're
going to need to work out what the line
is the first one is the point that's
that point P there and to specify P
given given X we need to know the the
level of Y which is of course just f of
X 0 now that's that's not a calculus
problem but anyway that's a very
important part of the process so that's
the first thing we need to know and the
second thing we need to know is the
slope and that's this number M and in
calculus we have another name for it we
call it f prime of x0 namely the
derivative of F so that's the calculus
part that's the tricky part and that's
the part that we have to discuss now so
just to make that explicit here I'm
going to make a definition which is that
f prime of x0 which is known as the
derivative
of F at x0 all right is the slope of the
tangent line to y equals f of X at the
point let's just call it P all right so
so that's what it is but still I haven't
made any progress in figuring out any
better how I drew that line so I have to
say something that's more concrete
because I want to be able to cook up
what these numbers are I have to figure
out what this number M is and one way of
thinking about that let me just try it
is so I certainly am taking for granted
that in sort of non calculus part that I
know what a line through a point is so I
know this equation but another
possibility might be you know this line
here how do I know unfortunately I
didn't draw it quite straight but there
it is how do I know that this orange
line is not a tangent line but this
other line is a tangent line well
it's it's actually not so obvious and
but I'm going to describe it a little
bit it's it's not really the fact this
thing crosses at some other place which
is this point q but it's not really the
fact that the thing crosses it to place
because the line could be Wiggly the
curve could be Wiggly and it could cross
back and forth a number of times that's
not what distinguishes the tangent line
so I'm going to have to somehow grasp
this and I first do it in language and
it's the following idea it's that if you
take this orange line which is called a
secant line and you think of the Q the
point Q is getting closer and closer to
P then the slope of that line will get
closer and closer to the slope of the
red line and if we draw it close enough
then that's going to be the correct line
so that's really what I did sort of in
my brain when I drew that first line and
so that's the way I'm going to
articulate it first now so the tangent
line is equal to the limit of what's
so-called secant lines PQ as Q tends to
P and here we're thinking of P is being
fixed and Q is very all right so so
that's the again this is still a
geometric discussion but now we're going
to be able to put symbols and formulas
to this computation and we'll be able to
to work out formulas in any example
so so let's do that so first of all I'm
going to write out these points P and Q
again so maybe we'll put P here and Q
here and I'm thinking of this line
through them I guess it was orange so
we'll leave it as orange all right and
now I want to compute its slope and so
this is gradually we'll do this in two
steps and these steps will introduce us
to the basic notations which are used
throughout calculus including
multivariable calculus across the board
so the first notation that's used is you
imagine here's the x-axis underneath and
here's the x0 the location directly
below the point P and we're traveling
here a horizontal distance which is
denoted by Delta X so that's Delta X so
called and we could also call it the
change in X all right so that's one
thing we want to measure in order to get
the slope of this line PQ and the other
thing is this height so that's this
distance here which we denote Delta F
which is the change in F and then the
slope is just the ratio Delta F over
Delta X so this is the slope of the of
the secant
and the process I just described over
here with this limit applies not just to
the whole line itself but also in
particular to its slope and the way we
write that is the limit as Delta X goes
to zero and that's going to be our slope
so this is the slope of the tangent line
okay now this is still a little a little
general and I'm going to I want to work
out a more usable form here I want to
work out a better formula for this and
in order to do that I'm going to write
Delta F the numerator more explicitly
here the change in F so remember that
the point P is the point X 0 f of X 0
alright that's what we got from our
formula for the point and in order to
compute these distances in particular
the vertical distance here I'm going to
have to get a formula for Q as well so
if this horizontal distance is Delta X
then this location is X 0 plus Delta X
and so the point above that point has a
formula which is X 0 plus sorry plus
Delta X F of and this is a mouthful X 0
plus Delta X all right so there's the
formula for the point Q here's the
formula for the point P and now I can
write a different formula for the
derivative which is the following so
this F prime of X 0 which is the same as
M is going to be the limit as Delta X
goes to 0 of the change in F well the
change in F is the value of F at the
upper point here which is x0 plus Delta
X and minus its value at the lower point
P which is f of x0 divided by Delta X
all right so this is the formula I'm
going to put this in a little box
because this is by far the most
important formula today which we use to
derive pretty much everything else and
this is the way that we're going to be
able to compute these numbers so let's
let's do an example
this example so we'll call this example
one we'll take the function f of X which
is 1 over X that's sufficiently
complicated to have an interesting
answer and sufficiently straightforward
that we can compute the derivative
fairly quickly so so what is it that
we're going to do here all we're going
to do is we're going to plug in this
this formula here for that function
that's that's all we're going to do and
visually what we're accomplishing is
somehow to take the hyperbola and take a
point on the hyperbola and figure out
some tangent line all right that's what
we're accomplishing when we do that so
we're accomplishing this geometrically
but we'll be doing it algebraically so
first we consider this difference Delta
F over Delta X and write out its formula
so I have to have a place so I'm going
to make it again above this point X 0
which is a general point we'll make the
general calculation so the value of F at
the top when we move to the right by f
of X so I just read off from this read
off from here the formula the first
thing I get here is 1 over X 0 plus
Delta X that's the left-hand term minus
1 over X 0 that's the right-hand term
and then I have to divide that by Delta
X ok so here's our expression and by the
way this has a name this thing is called
a difference quotient
it's pretty complicated because there's
always a difference in the numerator and
in disguise the denominator is a
difference because it's the difference
between the value on the right side and
the value on the left side here okay so
now we're going to simplify it by some
algebra so let's just take a look so
this is equal to let's continue on the
next level here this is equal to 1 over
Delta x times now all I'm going to do is
put it over a common denominator so the
common denominator is X 0 plus Delta X
times X 0 and so in the numerator for
the first expression I have X 0 and for
the second expression I have X 0 plus
Delta X so this is a the same thing as I
had in the numerator before factoring
out this denominator and here I put that
numerator into this more amenable form
and now there are two basic
cancellations the first one is that X 0
and X 0 cancel so we have this and then
the second step is that these two
expressions cancel right the numerator
and denominator now we have a
cancellation that we can make use of so
we'll write that under here and this is
equals minus 1 over X 0 plus Delta X
times X 0 and then the very last step is
to take the limit as Delta X tends to 0
and now we can do it before we couldn't
do it why because the numerator and the
Dominator gave us 0 over 0 but now that
I've made this cancellation I can pass
to the limit and all that happens is I
set this Delta X equal to 0
and I get minus 1 over X zero squared
alright so that's the answer
all right so in other words what I've
shown when we put it up here is that f
prime of X zero is minus 1 over X 0
squared now let's let's look at the
graph just a little bit to check this
for plausibility all right what's
happening here is first of all it's
negative right it's less than 0 which is
a good thing you see that slope there is
negative that's the simplest check that
you could make and the second thing that
I would just like to point out is that
as X goes to infinity that as if as we
go farther to the right it gets less and
less steep so less and whoops as X go x0
goes to infinity not not 0 as X 0 goes
to infinity less and less steep so
that's also consistent here if when X 0
is very large this is a smaller and
smaller number in in magnitude although
it's always negative it's always sloping
down all right so I've managed to fill
the boards so maybe I should stop for a
question or two yes
so the question is to explain again this
limiting process so the formula here is
we have basically two numbers so in
other words why is it that this
expression when Delta X tends to 0 is
equal to minus 1 over X zero squared let
me let me illustrate it by sticking in a
number for X 0 to make it more explicit
alright so for instance let me stick in
here for X 0 the number 3 then it's
minus 1 over 3 plus Delta X times 3
that's the situation that we've got and
now the question is what happens is this
number gets smaller and smaller and
smaller and gets to be practically 0
well literally what we can do is just
plug in 0 there then you get 3 plus 0
times 3 in the denominator minus 1 in
the numerator so this tends to tends to
minus 1 over 9 over 3 squared and that's
what I'm saying in general with this
with this extra number here other other
questions yes
so the question is how what happened
between this step and this step right
explain this this step here alright so
there were two parts to that the first
is this Delta X which is sitting in the
denominator I factored all the way out
front and so what's in the parentheses
is supposed to be the same as what's in
the numerator of this other expression
and then at the same time as doing that
I put that expression which is a
difference of two fractions I expressed
it with a common denominator so in the
denominator here you see the product of
the denominators of the two fractions
and then I just figured out what the
numerator had to be without really yeah
other questions okay so now so I claim
that on the whole calculus is gets a bad
rap that it's actually easier than most
things but it has there's a perception
that it's that it's that it's harder and
so I really have a duty to to give you
the calculus made harder story here so
we have to make things harder because
that's that's our job and this is what
actually what most people do in calculus
and it's the reason why calculus has a
bad reputation so the secret is that
when people ask problems in calculus
they generally ask them in context and
there are many many other things going
on and so the little piece of the
problem which is calculus is actually
fairly routine and has to be isolated
and gotten through but all the rest of
it relies on everything else you learned
in mathematics up to this stage from
grade school to through high school so
so that's the complication so now we're
going to do a little bit of calculus
made hard
by talking about a word problem now we
we only have one sort of word problem
that we can pose because all we've
talked about is this geometry point of
view so so far those are the only kinds
of word problems we can pose so what
we're going to do is just pose such a
problem so find the areas of triangles
enclosed by the axes and the tangent to
y equals 1 over okay so that's a
geometry problem and let me draw a
picture of it it's practically the same
as the picture for example one of course
so here's we're only consider the first
quadrant here's our shape all right it's
the hyperbola and here's maybe one of
our tangent lines which is coming in
like this and then we're trying to find
this area here all right so there's our
problem so why does it have to do with
calculus it has to do with calculus
because there's a tangent line in it and
so we're going to need to do some
calculus to to answer this question but
as you'll see the calculus is the easy
part so so let's get started with this
problem first of all I'm going to label
a few things and one important thing to
remember of course is that the curve is
y equals 1 over X that's perfectly
reasonable to do and also we're going to
calculate the areas of the triangles and
you could ask yourself in terms of what
well we're going to have to pick a point
and give it a name and since we need a
number we're going to have to do more
than geometry we're going to have to do
of this analysis just as we've done
before so I'm going to pick a point and
consistent with the labeling we've done
before I'm going to call it x0 y0 so
that's almost half the battle
having notations x and y for the
variables and x0 and y0 for the for the
specific point now once you see that you
have these labelings
I hope it's reasonable to do the
following so first of all this is the
point x0 and over here is the point y0
that's something that we're used to in
graphs and in order to figure out the
area of this triangle it's pretty clear
that we should find the base which is
that we should find this location here
and we should find the height so we need
to find that value there all right so
let's let's go ahead and and do it so
how are we going to how are we going to
do this well
so let's let's just take a look so what
is it that we need to do I claim that
there's only one calculus step and I'm
going to put a star here for this
tangent line I have to understand what
the tangent line is now once I figured
out what the tangent line is the rest of
the problem is no longer calculus it's
just that slope that we need so what's
the formula for the tangent line put
that over here it's going to be Y minus
y 0 is equal to and here's the magic
number we already calculated it it's in
the box over there it's minus 1 over X 0
squared X minus X 0 so this is the only
bit of calculus in this problem but now
we're not done we have to finish it we
have to figure out all the rest of these
quantities so we can figure out the area
all right so how do we do that well to
find this point this has a name we're
going to find the so-called x-intercept
that's the first thing we're going to do
so to do that what we need to do is to
find where this horizontal line meets
that diagonal line and the equation for
the x-intercept is y equals 0 all right
so we plug in y equals 0 that's this
horizontal line and we find this point
so let's do that in 2 star so we get 0
minus oh one other thing we need to know
we know that y 0 is f of x 0 and f of X
is 1 over X so this thing is 1 over X 0
right and that's equal to minus 1 over X
0 squared and here's X and here's X 0
all right so in order to find this x
value I have to plug in one equation
into the other so this simplifies a bit
let's put let's see this is minus x over
x0 squared and this is plus 1 over X 0
because the x0 and x0 squared cancels
somewhat and so if I put this on the
other side I get X divided by x0 squared
is equal to 2 over X 0 and if I then
multiply through so that's what this
implies and if I multiply through by x0
squared I get X is equal to 2 X 0 ok
okay so I claim at this point we've just
calculated it's 2 X 0
now I'm almost done I need to get the
other one I need to get this one up here
now I'm going to use a very big shortcut
to do that so so the shortcut to the
y-intercept sorry yeah the y-intercept
is to use symmetry alright I claim I can
stare at this and I can look at that and
I know the formula for the y-intercept
it's equal to 2 y 0 all right that's
what that one is
so this one is 2 y 0 and the reason I
know this is the following so here's the
symmetry of the situation which is not
completely direct it's a kind of mirror
symmetry around the diagonal it involves
the exchange of X Y with y X so trading
the roles of X and y so the symmetry
that I'm using is that any formula to
get that involves X's and Y's if I trade
all the x's and replace them by Y's and
trade all the Y's and replace them by
X's then I'll have a correct formula on
the other way so everywhere I see a why
I'm making an X and everywhere I see an
X I make it a y this which will take
place so why is that that's because the
that's just an accident of this equation
that's because
so the symmetry explained is that the
equation is y equals 1 over X but that's
the same thing as X y equals 1 if I
multiply through by X which is the same
thing as x equals 1 over y so here's
where the X and the y get reversed okay
now if you don't trust this explanation
you can also get get the y intercept by
plugging x equals 0 into the into the
equation star okay we plugged y equals 0
in and we got the x value and you could
do the same thing analogously the other
way alright so I'm almost done with the
with the geometry problem and let's
let's finish it off now well let me hold
off for one second before I finish it
off what I'd like to say is just make
one more tiny remark right and this is
the hardest part of calculus in my
opinion so the hardest part of calculus
is that we call it one variable calculus
but we're perfectly happy to deal with
four variables at a time or five or any
number in this problem I had an X a Y
and X 0 and a wiser that's already four
different things they have various
interrelationships between them so of
course the manipulations we do with them
are algebraic and when we're doing the
derivatives we just consider one what's
known as one variable calculus but
really there are millions of variables
floating around potentially so that's
what makes things complicated
created and that's something that you
have to get used to now there's
something else which is more subtle in
that I think many people who teach the
subject or use the subject aren't aware
because they've already entered into the
language and they're not they're so
comfortable with it that they don't even
notice this confusion there's something
deliberately sloppy about the way we
deal with these variables the reason is
very simple there are already four
variables here I don't want to create
six names four variables or eight names
four variables and but really in this
problem there were about eight I just
slipped them by you so why is that well
notice that the first time that I got a
formula for Y zero here it was this
point and so the formula for y zero
which I plugged in right here was from
these the equation of the curve y 0
equals 1 over X 0 the second time I did
it I did not use y equals 1 over X I
used this equation here so this is not y
equals 1 over X that's the wrong thing
to do that's an easy mistake to make if
the formulas are all a blur to you and
you're not paying attention to where
they are on the diagram you see that
y-intercept of that x-intercept
calculation they're involved where this
horizontal line met this diagonal line
and y equals 0 represented this line
here so the sloppiness is that Y means
two different things and we do this
constantly because it's way way more
complicated not to do what concept to do
it it's much more convenient for us to
allow ourselves the flexibility to
change the role that this letter plays
in the middle of the of the computation
and similarly later on if I had done
this by this more straightforward method
for the y-intercept I would have set X
equal to zero that would have been this
vertical line which is x equals zero but
I didn't change the letter X when I
that because that would be a waste for
us so this this is this is one of the
main confusions that happens if you can
keep yourself straight you're you're a
lot better off and and as I say this is
this is this is one of the complexities
all right so now let's finish off the
problem on let me finally get this area
here so actually I'll just finish it off
right here so the area of the triangle
is well it's the base times the height
the base is 2 X 0 the height is 2 y 0
and a half of that so it's 1/2 2 X 0 x 2
y 0 which is 2 X 0 y 0 which is low and
behold - so the amusing thing in this
case is it actually didn't matter what X
0 and y 0 are we get the same answer
every time that's just an accident of
the function 1 over X happens to be the
function with that property alright so
we have still have more business today
serious business so let me continue so
first of all I want to give you a few
more notations and these are just other
ways that people refer notations that
people use to refer to derivatives and
the first one is the following we
already wrote y is equal to f of X and
so when we write Delta Y that means the
same thing is Delta F that's a typical
notation and previously we wrote F prime
for the derivative so this is this is
this is Newton's notation for the
derivative okay but there are other
notations and one of them is DF DX and
another one is dy DX meaning exactly the
same thing and sometimes we let the
function slip down below so that becomes
d by DX of F or D by DX of Y so these
are all notations that are used for the
derivative and these were initiated by
live notes and these notations are used
interchangeably sometimes practically
together they both turn out to be
extremely useful
this one omits notice that this thing
omits
the underlying base point x0 that's one
of the nuisances it doesn't give you all
the information but there are lots of
situations like that we're where people
leave out some of the important
information you have to fill it in from
context so that's another couple of
notations so now I have one more
calculation for you today I carried out
this calculation of the derivative of
the of the the derivative of the
function 1 over X I want to take care of
some other powers so let's do that
so example 2 is going to be the function
f of X is X to the N N equals one two
three one of these guys and now what
we're trying to figure out is the
derivative with respect to X of X to the
N in our new notation what this is equal
to so again we're going to form this
expression Delta F Delta X and we're
going to make some algebraic
simplification so what we plug in for
Delta F is X plus Delta X to the N minus
X to the N divided by Delta X now before
let me just stick this in and I'm going
to erase it before I wrote x0 here
and x0 there but now I'm going to get
rid of it because in this particular
calculation it's a nuisance I don't have
an X floating around which means
something different from the x0 and I
just don't want to have to keep on
writing all those symbols it's a waste
of blackboard energy there's a total
amount of energy that I'm you know I've
already filled up so many blackboards
that it's just a limited amount of plus
I'm trying to conserve chalk okay anyway
no zeros so think of X is fixed again in
this case Delta X moves and X is fixed
in this in this calculation all right
now in order to simplify this in order
to understand it algebraically what's
going on I need to understand what the
nth power of a sum is and that's a
famous formula we only need a little
tiny bit of it called the binomial
theorem so the binomial theorem by no
meal
theorem which is in your text and
explained in a in an exercise says in an
appendix sorry says that if you take the
sum of two guys and you take them to the
nth power that of course is X plus Delta
X multiplied by itself and times and so
the first term is X to the N that's when
all of the N factors come in and then
you could have this factor of Delta X
and all the rest X's so at least one
term of the form X to the N minus one
times Delta X and how many times does
that help well it happens when there's a
factor from here from the next factor
and so on and so on and so on there's a
total of n possible times that that
happens and now the great thing is that
with this alone all the rest of the
terms are junk that we won't have to
worry about
so to be more specific the junk there's
a very careful notation for the junk the
junk is what's called Big O of Delta x
squared what that means is that these
are terms of order so with Delta x
squared Delta X cubed or higher
alright that's how very exciting
higher-order terms okay so this is the
only algebra that we need to do and now
we just need to combine it together to
get our result so now I'm going to just
carry out the cancellations that we need
so here we go we have Delta F over Delta
X which remember was 1 over Delta X
times this which is this x now this is X
to the n plus N X to the N minus 1 Delta
X plus this junk term minus X to the N
all right so that's what we have so far
based on our previous calculations now
I'm going to do the main calc
cancellation which is this alright so
that's 1 over Delta X times n X to the n
minus 1 Delta X plus this term here and
now I can divide in by Delta X so I get
n X to the N minus 1 plus now it's o of
Delta X there's at least one factor of
Delta X naught 2 factors of Delta X
because I have to cancel one of them and
now I can just take the limit in the
limit this term is going to be 0 that's
why I called it junk originally because
it disappears and in math junk is
something that goes away so this tends
to as Delta X goes to 0 and X to the N
minus 1 and so what I've shown you is
that D by DX of X to the N minus sorry n
is equal to n X to the N minus 1 so now
this is going to be super important to
you right on your problem set in every
possible way and I want to tell you one
thing one way in which it's very
important in one way that extends it
immediately so this thing extends to
polynomials
we got quite a lot out of this one
calculation namely if I take D by DX of
something like X cubed plus 5x to the
10th power that's going to be equal to
3x squared that's applying this rule to
X cubed and then here I'll get 5 times
10 so 50 x to the 9th so this is the
type of thing that we get out of it
and we're going to make more hay with
that next time what I turn myself off
yes the question is the question was the
binomial theorem only works when X Delta
X goes to 0 no the binomial theorem is a
general formula which also specifies
exactly what the junk is it's very much
more detailed but we only needed this
part we didn't care what all these crazy
terms were it's it's it's junk for our
purposes now because we don't happen to
need any more than those first two terms
yes because the Delta X goes to 0 ok see
you next time